françois christophe ursule et bonjour
oui bonjour bonjour à tous les auditeurs
de martinique 1ère vous êtes candidat
pour l'élection municipale au françois
pour quelles raisons avez vous décidé de
solliciter les suffrages de la
population franciscaine et peut-être
voulez vous bien nous dire très
succinctement quel est votre parcours
jusque là puisque vous vous êtes un
jeune candidat et vous êtes nouveau en
politique
exactement je suis le candidat de 48 ans
donc effectivement jeunes candidats
totalement nouveau en politique et on le
revendique
puisque je n'ai jamais participé à une
élection et en tant que tête de liste et
également faisant partie d'une liste
donc 7
cette nouveauté nous la revendiquons
parce que notre liste
elle est placée sous le signe du liste
citoyenne
aujourd'hui que vous ne parliez
effectivement des motivations de notre
liste
notre participation aux élections
municipales en 2020 en france soir
résulte d'un constat celui d'une crise
de la démocratie locale en particulier
la démocratie participative
il faut savoir coûte dernières élections
en 2014 moins de 60 % du corps électoral
s'est déplacé pour pouvoir voter et
l'équipe sortante a été élu avec moins
de 30% des inscrits très clairement
c'est deux chiffres témoignent d'une
crise de mon point de vue de la
démocratie participative et aujourd'hui
nous voulons présenter une offre
politique nouvelle de gens qui ne sont
pas des professionnels de la politique
mais qui veulent s'investir sur leur
commune qui viennent de tous horizons
politiques de droite de gauche
classiquement et qui souhaitent
aujourd'hui s'investir au delà des
étiquettes politiques mais qui se
retrouvent tous autour d'un projet celui
que nous avons intitulé construire
ensemble le françois de demain alors si
vous êtes élu maire vous et votre épique
votre équipe parce que j'ai moi quelle
sera votre chantier prioritaire quel est
le dossier qui appelle une urgence
extrême françois selon vous alors nous
avons dégagé aujourd'hui trois grands
axes et nous allons aujourd'hui détaillé
notre projet notre programme municipal
autant de ces trois grands axes
le premier s'est doté le territoire
d'aménagements et d'équipements
structurants pour améliorer le cadre de
vie des franciscains et surtout
accroître l'attractivité de la commune
ça c'est le premier axe le deuxième axe
c'est des actions sociales fortes pour
une ville solidaire et pour pouvoir
relier le lien intergénérationnel et le
lien social est en fait bien évidemment
pour une liste qui se dit citoyenne la
démocratie locale et la participation
citoyenne au coeur d'une action publique
efficace
il est temps aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
redonner du crédit à la parole politique
il est temps aujourd'hui que l'action
politique soit efficace les électeurs
ils en ont marre d'entendre des
promesses pas suivies d'effet en tout
cas c'est ce que l'on entend lorsqu'on
va au contact de la population est pour
nous très clairement nous inscrivons
l'efficacité de l'action publique au
coeur de notre projet elle vous parliez
effectivement d'actions prioritaires il
y en a une qui me tient à coeur c'est la
mise hors d'eau de la ville
on en parle trop souvent ça fait 50 ans
qu'on en parle aujourd'hui on a
simplement des solutions alternatives le
dragage des rivières ce n'est pas
suffisant il est temps aujourd'hui
d'avoir une vraie étude pour pouvoir
avoir un vrai plan de construction d'une
mise hors d'eau de la ville et ça fera
partie de nos chantiers prioritaires
mais pas seulement celui là il ya un
certain nombre d'équipements
structurants qu'il convient de mettre en
oeuvre françois pour redonner
effectivement une attractivité à cette
commune alors un peu dans la même veine
pour vous quel est l'enjeu le principal
enjeu du prochain scrutin qu'est-ce qui
va se jouer en mars 2020 pour la ville
du françois
alors le contexte est le suivant nous
avons une équipe sortante qui a géré la
ville pendant 24 ans et donc vous
imaginez bien que l'enjeu est
fondamental la question c'est est-ce que
nous poursuivons effectivement sur la
même dynamique
ou est-ce que nous changeons de
dynamique pas seulement changer d'équipé
parce que bien évidemment tout je vis
avec mes concurrents se présente
effectivement sous le signe du
changement mais nous on dit qui lit on a
besoin de vrais changements
et pour pouvoir avoir ce vrai chambord
françois il faut pas seulement changer
les hommes il faut également changer les
pratiques politiques et notre liste
s'inscrit effectivement dans cette
mouvance citoyenne où nous voulons
changer les pratiques politiques et pas
seulement les hommes
donc c'est un enjeu fondamental
pour les prochaines années au françois
parlé d' usure du pouvoir évidemment
d'une d'une équipe d'une majorité
l'acquis en place en effet depuis
plusieurs années mais qui présente un
candidat
alors je sais pas si on peut le
présenter comme un candidat tout nouveau
mais en tout cas sûr et certain c'est
quand même à un jeune homme quoi donc ça
peut peut-être je dirais qu'on pensait
la longévité des mandatures
écoutez on ne change pas on ne change
pas la maison simplement en changeant la
devanture est en fait on propose aux
franciscains de rejouer exactement le
même match qu'en 2014 il n'y a pas que
le candidat que vous citez il ya
également les principaux candidats est
en fait sans l'intervention d'un autre
liste aujourd'hui sans la participation
de notre liste on nous propose
simplement exactement le même match
qu'en 2014 et nous aujourd'hui on
apporte une offre politique différente
avec des pratiques politiques
différentes et je vous annonce
aujourd'hui que nous allons dans le cas
de la construction de notre programme
lancé une grande consultation citoyenne
et ce sont les franciscains à partir des
actes nous avons défini qui vont
contribuer à construire ce projet pour
construire ensemble françois de demain
françois à christophe ursulet merci
merci